TikToK is a goldmine for the latest trends and tricks,
and even that includes cleaning!
Mm-hmm.
Okay, this is so exciting,
I can't wait, one woman racked up 26 million views
for a hypnotic video of her cleaning and restocking
the snack drawer of her fridge.
I could watch this all day long.
No, it's so brilliant!
She's a mom from Michigan who cleans
and comms with every TikToK video she posts,
and guess what Rossie?
What?
She's here.
I know!
(screaming)
Please, welcome Monica Brady.
Hi Monica,
(all clapping)
Hi.
Oh my gosh!
I'm so excited to be here with you guys.
Aw!
Oh, we feel the same way about you
and what an impressive
thing that you've done Monica,
procuring millions and millions
and not like three, four or five,
I'm talking like 25, 30 million people
are watching your videos.
Why do you think that they're so hypnotizing
and people are so drawn to them?
What's the secret?
So I just really feel like with ASMR in cleaning videos,
at least this is the feedback that I've gotten
from like my followers,
is they're really motivating for people.
Like they'll be after dinner
and there'll be, you know, relaxing and enjoying their meal,
and, (chuckles)
and they're like, "Oh, I just came across this TikTok
"and she's organizing her fridge
"or she's cleaning something."
And it just really motivates my followers
and they reach out to me
and they just love it and it just motivates them.
And I just love producing this kind of content
for people because of that.
Well, it motivated me I have to say,
I watched your video and then I attacked my refrigerator
(chuckles)
I really did, this weekend,
and I cleaned it and turned all the labels forward
because you gave me refrigerator envy.
But for people who think that they can't do that,
where do we start?
Hmm, good question.
You start small, would be my biggest piece of advice
and if anybody's new and starting an organization
I would really recommend
just like mapping out your fridge;
like where do you want the produce to go?
Where do you want the drinks to go?
Where do you want the snacks to go?
Just if everything is right up front and just easy to grab
like the produce is washed,
you know how many drinks do you have,
you know what drinks you have.
There's less likely to be waste in the fridge,
and there's less likely to be waste of food as well,
at least that's how it is in our home.
That we've, you know...
Everything gets eaten for the most part. (chuckles)
Yeah, if you can see it, you don't waste it,
it makes sense, right?
Right, right.
Now it's not just refrigerators,
okay right, you also went viral for a little laundry hack?
Tell us about that.
It did.
So, back beginning of COVID actually,
my husband and I redid our laundry space,
and he put a shelf up above the washer and dryer,
and I put all, you know, my laundry products up there.
And I was like, "This is really disappointing
"because the laundry containers are ugly."
And I found these gorgeous glass...
Glass jars, that are actually like beverage dispensers.
Yeah, they're like you would put lemonade
or ice tea in on of these.
Yeah.
I think they're actually advertised
as an iced tea dispenser
and they're only $6,
I'm like, "Oh, this is awesome."
So I bought those.
That's such a brave idea.
So you don't have like neon jug on display,
you can have this cute little thing.
And then one day I just decided,
you know, I'm like, "Hey I'm going to film this.
"I feel like it's something TikToK would like."
And it completely blew up,
and that's where my TikToK platform started actually.
(chuckles)
Well, Monica, what I love about what you're doing
is that it's leading functionality, and tips,
and ways to organize and make life prettier.
I am so into what you're doing.
I'm so happy-
Thank you.
That it's getting so much recognition and I enjoy it.
I understand.
Yeah, I feel like I've learned so much from you, Monica.
Thanks for all these tips.
(chuckles) Oh my gosh, I'm fangirling so much,
'cause I love both of you,
and you guys like literally watch my TikToks,
I'm so excited.
Oh, we really did.
Well, Monica come back and teach us more, seriously.
(chuckles) Oh, anytime, anytime.
(upbeat music)